الخيمه السعوديه باتت ملتقى السينمائيين
وصناع السينما من كل انحاء العالم حيث
تشهد هذه الخيمه حوارات مفتوحه وندوات
متخصصه وقد اشادت اداره مهرجان كان
السينمائي بدعم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وببرنامجها الدعم لسينما الشباب بالتاكيد
نحن نعرف ان العديد من الدول ومنذ فتره
طويله تعمل على دعم السينما في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والتي تقوم بدعم الشباب
وتجاربهم السينمائيه
الصندوق الثقافي اطلق برنامج الاستثمار في
قطاع الافلام بميزانيه تبلغ 300 مليون
ريال سعودي ضمن مبادره تمويل القطاع
الافلام والتي يبلغ اجمالي ميزانيتها نحو
879 مليون ريال سعودي وهي احدى مبادرات
برنامج المحتوى الرقمي كما نظمت فيلم
العلا برنامج العلا لتطوير المواهب فيما
يقوم الجناح السعودي بالتعريف بمواقع
التصوير لافلام الهوليديه الكبرى في
نيويورك وبعض المناطق التاريخيه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بشكل عام اصبح الايه يلتفت بشكل اوضح
واكثر جديه للجناح السعودي الذي منذ
انطلقنا وهو مزدحم كما ترون واعتقد ان
الاسم
اصبح اسما صعبا لا يمر بسهوله واصبحت خيمه
العرب هذه تلفت الانظار في اين محلت ونظمت
هيئه الافلام عده حوارات مفتوحه عن مختلف
الاختصاصات السينمائيه وعن كيفيه القيام
بتصوير وانتاج فيلم في السعوديه بمشاركه
نخبه من المختصين في السينما ومخرجين من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وندوات عن جذب
الاستثمار في قطاع السينما كما يشارك
مهرجان البحر الاحمر وشركه
واثراء ووزاره الاستثمار ووفد من المخرجين
والمواهب السعوديه ويقدمون يوميا نشاطا عن
مستقبل صناعه السينما في السعوديه خليه
عمل سينمائيه يوميه يشهدها هذا الجناح
السعودي في مهرجان كان السينمائي ندوات
وحوارات مفتوحه لمختلف الاختصاصات
السينمائيه وتوقيع اتفاقات لتبادل الخبرات
هو جانب الاستثمارات السينمائيه سعد
المسعودي العربيه مهرجان كان سينمائي
فرنسا
تقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات